hello everybody welcome to the comedy
film nerds a TC podcast comedy festival
lie live bonus app yeah this is pretty
exciting we're gonna thank our the
sponsor but like oh yeah let's listen to
this oh wow that's a delicious yeah
pretend beer cap like everyone knows I
don't drink but if I did it would be a
Bud Light it would taste so amazing and
it would be yeah and someday it'll be a
coconut water thank you everybody for
coming out to the show today and it's
sold out oh my god yeah I'd say a
thousand people would you put it at 950
on the low-end concern all right that
might be exaggerating a little bit
there's 800 people I mean we all every
every time we do one of these shows on
the road live we always have to like pay
the fire marshal a little extra yeah
give a little you know that's fire money
we always have a fire money budget very
happy that Aaron brung GART made it out
here you set up the studio with all the
equipment he made it out here I survived
guys yeah and it all together you put
this entire thing together
oh yeah he's wearing a Cardinals hat
just as a deliberate [ __ ] you to me as a
couple maybe just one just one a Brit
shot one last time so one last time and
we're also in the same place you could
buy a TC merge so people might be buying
a shirt in the middle of our podcast I
hope I hope a couple of stickers go
while we're talking about Matthew
McConaughey project that would be
excellent so so but this is uh this is
one of our few episodes where that
streaming live we are streaming live so
everybody watching live thank you No
thank you so much for tuning in
first-ever ATC Comedy Festival happy to
be a part of it have you be a part of it
we're in a beautiful hotel mm-hmm I
already abused the pool nice indoor
outdoor outdoor Arizona
everything's outside everything's
outside there's no roof on the hotel
it's just a bunch of Quonset huts tacked
on yeah yeah it's like a tent city right
and it's a you know but four-star tent
city yeah it's like ready player one
right I mean it's like that type of
environment that's what penis is so this
is fantastic it'll warm well it was just
95 in LA yeah
no I'm saying it's you don't need to the
co going to Phoenix gonna be much cooler
nope no no what you think Phoenix is
gonna be no I knew it was gonna be works
nope
you know Arizona is a hotter state I
don't like going outside so it doesn't
matter I think this is Chris's first
time in the state of Phoenix yeah or the
city yes whoa somebody just opened the
door our Dean's just doubled oh my
goodness so welcome come on in did you
want a shirt or a sticker
they're like spotlight sir well you can
buy one yeah sponsors all right so let's
um anything else we need to announce or
talk about or we could just get right to
introducing our guests this is a special
show tonight it's a special showing a
lot of a lot of ways first of all this
guest and I met when we were students at
the University of Arizona Wow just down
the road in Tucson mm-hmm and I haven't
seen each other in forever mm-hmm we
both live in LA and yet we have to come
to Arizona to see so you lost track of
each other but you've kind of reunited
we've reunited yeah he also has become a
filmmaker in a comic and he's gonna he's
gonna tell us all about it what he's got
going on ladies and gentlemen Mike Young
welcome him to the hot corner of the ATC
stage welcome welcome
so Mike you guys could you know
reconcile your differences I know you
guys had a feud going for many years two
guys that lost touch
yeah so what he been up to the last 15
years first of all let it let it be
known that Graham was inspirational I'm
not I'm not just saying in in me doing
comedy in college I was like dreaming
about doing stand-up scared to do
stand-up we knew each other not even I
didn't even know you were doing stand-up
I go to a huge show at the auditorium
it's 88 whatever year it is Barry soul
was performing packed
house he gets up and opens for Barry
Silva and crushes crushes mm-hmm very
simple had a very tough time the social
build what we like do we ever in the
same dorm or we were on a flag football
team together Navy flag football recruit
heavily for six weeks before I was
thrown out but it was only because when
you were on a flag football scholarship
right the intramural money was yeah I
was driving a 300zx right next to Chris
Mills football but I just had to tell
you you crushed it in front of Barry
Sobel got me over my fear of stand up
just to let you know and then the beef
began nice because you see him for you
so la yeah and it was about very Sobel
it was interesting who I still see once
I can't believe well yes because I do
always took that as well if Graham can
do it yeah yeah he was killing it at a
high level for a very long yeah yeah it
was awesome and I'm trying to think of
the last time I saw you like I would see
your name like cuz you perform at The
Comedy Store a lot right yeah I'm a
comedy store guy right and then then I'm
an improv guy yep so never the twain
shall meet
you know no but I would see you at like
random offshoots of like I forgot who's
our buzz Sam remember Sam Brown that was
a really cool alt room and I would see
you there once in a while and I was like
we'd cross paths once in a while but
like never you know I went my way you
know you know the Jews do it you got
your improv skills I was all stand up
well cool and then you've you've done
well get into a little later but you've
also you've directed some stuff and yes
yes I've been directing movies for the
last seven years
quite a journey you know stand up stand
up stand up the whole time and then
caught a lucky break was something that
I wrote and then while they were
actively looking for a director I
convinced them
that I could direct it's really how it
went I think that's half of directing it
really it really is you got a ghost no
no I can do this well you know no I can
do this you just like have to like camp
out in front of somebody's house long
enough here's how I would do it yeah
yeah wait were you media arts yeah I was
meeting okay so we had a couple clubs
that's right that's what it was and if
you study film television radio in
Arizona at the U of A you can't direct
there's no skill they gave us well he
left school with no skills right so when
I said I could do it I truly was
biessing my way into my first movie but
it all worked out because I've read a
bunch you know I read Woody Allen's
books and I read about you know
Playboy's interviews with every director
and so many of them were like if you
understood the rhythm and you understood
the timing and you knew where to get out
and you knew how to you know I mean then
you'd be fine so that's really the
mentality I was not a filmmaker in
college yeah I think III I took some
film production classes but learned real
I mean it was Oh some of us I learned
some okay stuff but I think it was right
I read a lot of those books too like
Sidney Lumet's book yeah our program was
a radio TV and film RTF but then it was
always nicknamed rather than fail which
probably I still I was right there it
was it was one of those things where we
we actually did filmmaking we had the
only film lab in Philadelphia so
actually the other schools would
actually come and develop film at Temple
University and but at the same time you
know we were still editing on you know
two VHS players and then you know with
this is like it really felt like the
Dark Ages where we were cutting film
with like a razor blade and like helping
him back together that was all yes I
tell people like oh I cut eight and
sixteen millimeter yeah and literally
had to put the strips and hang them and
like don't lose them yeah in case you
want to do it again then try to sync up
the sound with the sound the synchronize
and all those things and then the grad
students got the steamed back like those
were that was the expensive editing says
yeah I learned how to shoot on a Bolex
right the windup see what you want
mm-hmm
you know what I shot I really I didn't
take anything seriously back then I
think I had I've had all of those
digitized or well not no no I had them
put on a half inch tape and so I just
need to digitize that but like I could
put my college film real I should do
that and put it on YouTube cuz it's like
pretty amazing were you guys were you
were you going to like those studios and
doing like talk show stuff to like
remember they had like the home studio
yes go with the accent yes yeah so III
did that was my first talk show you guys
didn't see it about the life of a
stripper literally but I had a show I
had a talk show there so that was like
we would cross paths in that world
that's that's how I sorta and then we
would we all cuz me and my roommate
Petey martini were also seeking I
remember security guards at the football
ball games you did not want to mess
around and you if you saw me grab MP
that's right that was you that was your
part-time job you guys were security
guys in the world we got paid to watch
football Wow and then basketball the
basketball team was really good so the
tickets were really hard to see any
action do you ever have to deal with any
trouble nothing literally storm the gold
yeah the field-goal rip it right down
we're making six bucks an hour
scrap for that but then I remember for
the the basketball games we knew this
ticket scalper and then we would sell
standing room only tickets and we'd
sneak guys in the side door yeah I
wasn't on that do you Chicago and
Detroit I made four hundred thousand my
freshman year didn't make another dime
since you figured out it buddy you
figured out a scam of course we do we
had every scam working man cuz Pete was
from New York I was through Chicago Mike
was from Detroit so we were just like
well what's the angle the freshman we
would hustle people in for free tickets
we mailed ripped their cars oh we were
selling rims and everything
it was Tucson bro it was and then I
remember we were such mooches then all
the concessions would have to throw away
and we'd like you has got any extra
pizzas I mean we'd have pizzas and hot
dogs for like a week mm-hmm and it was
the nastiest we ate at all you know no
it was an amazing time well my brother
ended up walking on the football team on
a few my little brother one walked out
as a wide receiver so that just took my
scalping game to the next level of
course we got into show business because
show business is a filthy scam florida
hustle fully funded by the cartels Sony
yeah okay Sony okay well actually we
actually had an amazing education at
Arizona we got you want to start with
that gold alright I'll talk about gold
okay we wanted for this for this episode
since we just did a regular episode to
kind of talk about some movies maybe
that that we missed on the first goal
whereas on the first go around and just
some things that maybe fell through the
cracks in us we're gonna hit Mike's
gonna tell us about get his take on some
movies we've talked about as well so I
wanted to talk about gold because it was
one of those movies that was Matthew
McConaughey it came out it looked good
it looked good it was definitely it was
definitely trying to get some Oscar buzz
right so you when you have an a-list
movie star making themselves ugly that's
like I like the fact that this is his
third film about searching for gold that
after Sahara in 2005 and fool's gold in
if you got something about gold you go -
Makani yeah exactly
he's the gold guy if you want that or
weird cryptic psychedelic Lincoln
commercials like that Jackie
McConaughey's you're the worst and
weirdest [ __ ] I've ever so weird is
going on I don't know what it is he's
talking about bowling the one I don't
know yes I know he's on some high level
marijuana's I'd love to know it's like
if it was selling cars like what's the
conversion rate of Matthew McConaughey
and a Cadillac commercial crazy one the
hybrid one where he's like it's not
about selling tree or hugging trees what
are you talking about
it's literally honestly it's I feel like
it's Lincoln dads are really like
Colonel Kurtz going up the river in
Apocalypse Now like he lost his [ __ ]
he's got a Montaner d'armée he's just up
somewhere in outside of Austin amassing
a Lincoln Army and he's talking to Baal
and he thinks he's shooting a movie
hundred percent yeah he has no idea this
is a campaign right keep shooting these
out of order I don't understand so
that's what gold is yeah I didn't see it
now it's based on an actual scandal
right it's based on an actual scandal
it's actually on Netflix so it's worth
it's it's one of those you're at home
and you don't know what to do and you're
looking for something to watch and
you're like it was that's what I did I
was like oh yeah you know what I wanted
to check this out this is a Netflix
original movie no because in this it was
in this theaters it tried to make an
Oscar push it didn't get it for whatever
reason it just didn't take got it it
didn't make I don't know where where it
didn't connect there's some good stuff
in it
maybe it's like people just went oh it's
no Dallas buyers club or something I
don't know which was like his finest
role yeah and that movie was pretty much
great beginning to end right if you've
got a couple major hiccups you're not
going Oscar I think probably only the
only person who can do that is Meryl
Streep she's the only one who can do a
movie that's like okay and she'll still
get a nomination yeah just because she's
Meryl Streep yeah but so there's some
interesting stuff in this it's about
this guy and he plays who's a hustler
and like you kind of get an insight into
the gold game which makes sense the gold
game sounds like us as freshmen and
it's all hustle and scam and letterhead
letterhead and getting the rights and
all we got the new you know and so
people are fudging stuff and it's all
the up and down of it and then once it
starts making money people come swooping
in and wanted to snatch him up but he's
kind of a it gets it gets a little long
I can kind of see where it lost its its
strength to potentially be an Oscar
contender because there's some moments
where just like it's both of those
things that you guys just said it lost
momentum and then they would try to sort
of force it back at times but as far as
a life watch at home Netflix it's great
for that like it's but I was like oh
that's why I'd lost it right you know
he's he does a great performance as this
guy guy can act he can act on he can i
he can act he feels he feels I mean I I
mean they should put the Lincoln ads on
a compilation DVD and just like
Criterion Lincoln Matt McConaughey so so
there's some really there's some really
cool stuff in it and it was there's
really good supporting characters in it
right and it's one of those things
that's like it it slipped through the
cracks for the Oscars but it's still a
really solid film and if you never got a
chance to see it and you like Matt
McConaughey I absolutely recommend
watching is it kind of like a UH like a
rise and fall kind of type story where
it's like you know they're looking for a
goal they can't find it they finally
find that they then everyone wants a
piece and it just kind of goes like up
and down like a almost like a Scarface
yeah go like that and then you know he
does the thing he puts on 45 pounds when
in the first scene you see him with a
punch and I'm like is that it is that a
prosthetic is that a pregnancy and then
and then yeah I thought it was all he
wouldn't big belt but then there's a
scene he takes his shirt off and you're
like all right and he's got these
messed-up teeth and well ain't like
burgers and milkshakes something like
that
I thought it was gonna be his Raging
Bull yeah yeah in the gold world exactly
so they start as a hustler and the movie
like was he already a scam artist or did
he gets put in that world
it starts out his dad and this is the
actual characters dad was like a a
champion in the gold world so he was
working for his dad's company
his dad was this like hero this man
amongst men like everybody revered him
and loved him and thought he was a great
guy so he was like trying to live up to
his dad's thing and then some I don't
wanna give away too much but then like
some stuff goes south and like you know
his dad passes away and so then he's
kind of battling a lot of those personal
sort of demons and the financial aspects
of it and then he's looking you know
he's convinced that there's this thing
and the Indonesian jungles that you know
like gold it's been untapped yeah so
then he starts chasing that ghost and so
but yeah it's there's you'll get to the
slow spots in the film but overall I
think you'll really I think you really
like it well it seems like there was a
lot of cast and director attachments and
changes like it was a was a hard movie
to get done like Michelle Williams was
cast in Lee but dropped out Bryce Dallas
Howard replaced her after filming had
already already begun and Christian Bale
was offered the lead role in Michael
Mann was set to direct so there was all
this you know you know backstage stuff
going on and you know what that might
have contributed to like Academy members
just kind of backing off backing off I'm
not gonna watch this or something like
that because you hear sometimes you hear
a lot of that you think oh this is gonna
be a bomb right and it wasn't it wasn't
a bomb right you can feel if a movie's
gone through turmoil sometimes like you
can look at him watch a movie go wait a
minute this they disappeared also they
ran out of money and stopped I didn't
have him for two weeks like things
happen like real [ __ ] goes down I think
it's like I've been here
yeah you feel that you're just like all
those actors hated each other or
whatever like you can just you could
feel it I think you see those grumblings
come out yeah in the in the in the
trades or whatever so it's worth
watching though all right I'll check it
on the couch check it out on the couch
one two good on streaming so I saw the
lost city of Z now this is one of the
movies that I really wanted to check out
and I finally got a chance to see it as
streaming on a different platform and
it's on Amazon Prime and I will say this
it's another guy losing his [ __ ] in the
jungle is that pretty pretty much--it's
yeah it's definitely a theme and I and
it has like for whatever reason this
movie itself had pages and pages and
pages of trivia like normally you don't
see that many you know pieces of trivia
but this one like I literally had to
call down there was so much going on
behind the scenes in this movie is based
on a book yeah and director James Gray
wrote to Frank Francis Ford Coppola who
directed Apocalypse Now again we were
talking about Kurtz and going up the
river for advice on shooting in the
jungle copal is two-word reply was don't
go
when Coppola decided to make Apocalypse
Now he received the same advice from
Roger Corman that's and well that's the
thing I think Coppola is the like one of
the few exceptions to the movie went
derailed or like you said Mike you can
sense when there's a lot of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that's one of the few movies where
all of the madness there's you and a
half years to make that movie you watch
the documentary on that filmmakers
apocalypse hearts of darkness that's the
one movie where you go it works it
worked
he created a masterpiece right yes and
this story far is about an explorer
played by Charlie Hunnam
who was convinced that there is a lost
city somewhere in the Amazon which would
but it also he called it Zed so I don't
even know why they shortened it to Z in
the title like what what does that sound
hipper for the kids lost city of Z maybe
no yeah we got to shorten this by two
letters it's actually it's actually how
the British say Z they don't say Z they
say said really yeah I said it in
England and someone was like they didn't
respond and they're like oh Zed you
means that yes American art it would
still look like a Z to us but they
pronounced it said how to steal places
he gave me an example of how horrifying
shooting in the jungle is Charlie Hunnam
remembers a particularly nerve-racking
encounter one Saturday night after an
exhausting six-day six day shooting week
I was staying in this little shack on
the hill and woke up 3:00 in the morning
to the Sun godly noise like there was a
pneumatic drill in my ear an insect had
burrowed into my ear and hit my eardrum
and couldn't go any further
it was a long beetle with wings when it
couldn't get back out it kept trying to
burrow further in and flapping its wings
my favorite part of this quote is the
next sentence that's what woke me up
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that's what really that's
where you must be a really deep sleeper
that's a four pill tonight it's funny I
heard so the movie The Rundown that came
down in 2003 with the rock here's a
talking about why everyone's like don't
shoot in the jungle so they initially
were like we're gonna shoot that in the
Amazon jungle and you know and the story
is I don't know how accurate this is but
it I like repeating it because it makes
sense here is they got there all their
stuff got stolen the crude laptops by
like some some get rebel army in the
jungle or bandits a bandit or whatever
and they were just like okay that's it
and then they shot the rest of movie and
our crew got robbed in in Detroit what
happens yeah and people see a truck with
half a million worth of equipment in it
and you're in the hood or the jungle
what and it's bait its bait it's a
hundred percent it's gone within eight
hours it's a it's a it's a great racket
we had to buy our own equipment back
well I know that my first question for
Mike is about his movie when we get to
that part of the show I called Coppola
what do I do in Detroit
don't shoot there Detroit yeah so stay
out so Hunnam played this explore faucet
who was obsessed with the basically he
was being sent down there to actually
make maps as he was like part of the car
cartographers society and they were
gonna send him down to actually make
maps but he found some pottery and he
got obsessed that there was like this
hidden city that no one could find and
he made multiple journeys this is where
the film gets a little long there was a
lot of back-and-forth like alright I'm
back in England alright now I'm going
back to the jungle to find the city now
I'm back in England again I'm leaving my
family again I'm like he said goodbye to
his family many times because there were
always these brakes on him trying to
find this the city and it also shows the
progression of you know his his oh the
son growing up and you know him pretty
much leaving his family to fend for
themselves played by Tom Holland when he
got older the son drove the spider-man
and this this made me laugh - Tom
Holland had to wear a fake mustache for
the movie because he said he was a child
and couldn't grow one yet that was to
make him older a fake mustache what was
weird as it looked like one of those
snidely whiplash mustache it's yeah you
could yeah I understand it's a period
piece I will say this this is another
movie that had a lot of changes so
Benedict Cumberbatch was originally
going to play Percy Fawcett but had to
drop out due to scheduling with dr.
strange and I think it would have been
maybe a little bit better with the Brit
goes Charlie Hunnam he's a decent actor
he's not fantastic let's be honest he's
not fantastic but he's decent he's a
decent actor he won yes he definitely
went to the Graham Elwood School of
Irish accents oh he's really putting a
lot of effort into that accent then
their scenes are like well now he's not
even trying but no well whatever
happened it's the accent goes in and out
so the bug got his ear yeah that would
be even funnier if he was actually no
I'm from Ireland
yeah yeah British he is English for sure
so I don't know what he was trying to do
with the accent but whatever it was it
was out fire with a bow yeah it was it
was a mixture of like sorry
yes this scene is mrs. Doubtfire the
scene is Sons of Anarchy so he really
just kind of picked which scene he was
in and that determined the strength of
the accident you know what this movie is
worth seeing with a fast-forward button
[Laughter]
it's it really wanted to be like a
period piece mixed with Indiana Jones
like you know you've got natives you've
got you know adventure you've got in the
jungle you've got explorers and like
mystery and like lost cities and all
these things on paper sound like this is
great but the way it was just kind of
put together was just kind of like well
first of all it could have been at least
30 to 40 minutes shorter and second of
all it was a little unsatisfying so I
feel like if somebody had to choose
between one of our guy loses his [ __ ] in
the jungle movies they were probably
going gold yeah I think it was a
definitely better guy was a [ __ ] in the
jungle movie or just the Apocalypse Now
a gold watch Apocalypse Now again yeah
and then the director's cut where they
have dinner with that crazy French
family and they steal his surfboard you
know even that still better than gold go
their loss is out it was such a weird
like like like
recasting - like Percy Fawcett was
originally supposed to be played by Brad
Pitt but then Brad in the director for
the role should be played by British
actor but that led to Benedict
Cumberbatch so and then he was all set
to go then there was problems with you
know shooting with dr. strange and then
eventually you know how do you go from
Brad Pitt
Benedict Cumberbatch to Charlie Hunnam
that's really an interesting I thought
was interesting what you just said is
that Brad Pitt and the director decided
that Brad Pitt wasn't right so I'm
wondering his Brad Pitt a producer on
that movie yes okay yes sure yeah he's
like get my money back or I just
envisioned Brad Pitt like he's he a
psychopath when he's talking producer he
refers to himself in the third person
like I just got I think Brad Pitt might
not be right for this role maybe
sometimes Brad Pitt's hard to work with
and Brad Pitt from now on only makes
movies with the word Z in them that's it
don't even call Pitt unless you got a Z
in the title forget it all right well I
want to hear what Mike you said you know
we just talked away I got to say one
more thing about this the jungles there
was so much trivia and it was so
horrifying like the shoot sounds like it
was an absolute nightmare
but I will say this it sounds like any
movie shot in the jungle was an
absolutely there was someone in the crew
got bitten in the neck by a snake and
the Colombians kept telling them there's
a reason you don't go off the path the
animals will leave you alone until you
start smashing the jungle that was the
advice stay on the path like like it's
like a hobbit going through Mirkwood
forest yes so I will say this you know
after reading all this trivia and seeing
like you know how hard it is to actually
shoot in the jungle there was an
appreciation for just the fact that they
got this movie made like they shot it on
35 millimeter film they said you know
the max weren't working with the
humidity like like every day seemed like
a challenge just to get stuff into the
can absolutely so it's a shame it's just
not a better movie it's or what if you
come back with malaria right yellow
fever
worth and then you have a story sounds
like there were multiple rewrites you
said that there was the part of the
movie where he kept going back and forth
yeah there was definitely multiple count
was like I don't like to it was like you
know like well you don't need to put
every scene from the book in the movie
like that really felt like you know how
many times we're gonna go back and forth
in the jungle I get it he's looking for
the lost city he doesn't need to look
for it four times
yeah no turning of turning a book to a
movies a whole nother animal yeah so
let's because we talked I wanted to hear
what you had to say about Marshall cuz I
talked about it on on the episode we
just released yeah cuz I actually watch
a lot of biopics what did you I felt
like Marshall was I wanted to go see a
really great indie film that was gonna
be like dark and tone and like feel edgy
but I just felt like it was forced and
it was like obviously the actors were
fine they would you guys have the same
reaction a fine job but get out of here
with your jazz score and your lighting
that looks like it's an ABC television
show if I'm watching like some hardcore
[ __ ] going down I don't want to see you
know for camera lighting schemes and
like it just the only studio that was
available but like the actors were
playing in a different film yeah he
should have been a stage play what's
funny they were attacked
no you make such a great point and and I
hadn't even considered that but that's
almost another thing why I had when you
say that as I can't that's what it was
like aesthetically in the for camera
shoot I was like man that's what because
his story Thorogood Marshalls story is
pretty intense and credible and they're
like all this jokey dialogue and then
like you say the wacky lighting and the
jazz music like this was a brutal time
yeah were you going for a tone that's
never been done before was invented a
tone like with like getting lynched yeah
it's life or death
my guys are saying it focused on a very
specific part of his life too because
this one trial but this trial was like
the heavy he was heavy it was so heavy
what was going on he couldn't even talk
at the trial he'd have Josh GAD
basically speak for him he was really
just the brains of the operation
so baqia because he was black he was he
was in the background of his own trial
but his own trials he's a genius he's
the smartest guy in the room and the
judge knew that it was like you don't
get to talk and so it's like looks like
Josh GAD is gonna be my branch or like
it was like and then how about like the
tight crazy weird close-ups that they
did like on the judge do you remember
like oksun like the judges face is like
it just wasn't making sense it was a
bummer because like I said the
performances were fine they were okay
but the tone was off the lighting was
off the score was off I bet you guys
missed a chance to tell a great stuff
great story I thought I can't go that
goes to the director really well because
I'm making movies and it's hard enough
just to make a movie but if I'm gonna
sit back and watch and we're gonna talk
about it I mean I did not enjoy that
movie I thought I was gonna go see a
movie then I was way into cuz I wanted
that story so great but they missed it
well though Chris it's not just the
directors fault on this it is part
because the director has directed a lot
of comedy TV which that's that seemed to
like be ish Reggie Hudlin yeah yeah and
but also the script oh okay and that was
the problem I had to was I felt like
they just took a biopic standard script
and just went boom boom boom and then
put in cute dialogue and even the heavy
moments they were like afraid to like
really live the heavy moments agree or
they put in this big swelling music
that's telling me what emotion I don't
need your music to tell me exactly
what's going on don't lead me into it
sounds like a punch it was like a like a
ABC that's what it felt like that's
exactly that's how it was shot that's
how it was directed that's what the
script was like that's how it was lit
yeah even the costuming felt like we're
just pulling this out of our 1940s era
rack at lifetime right yeah whatever
studio yeah they were on like what it
would all right let's see your wardrobe
department give me that rack like even
like they've got the savage beatings I
mean they both got beat down at the same
time in different places remember that
and then they came back and they're like
joking they're like joking about the
beatings and it was like whatever I
can't remember the joke but it's like
you you could take a punch it's like
we're in like we don't mean we're
this high-level racism KKK style light
necks coming at you dad murder yeah and
you guys are joking so I don't know who
the hell was coming up we need a comedy
punch yeah somebody did a comedy pass on
that we don't need comic relief we gotta
give Josh GAD something funny to say
with this that's might have been as
simple as something like that like this
guy so known for comedy we got to give
him something funny we don't want the
audience to be disappointed that he's in
our movie and not funny it really didn't
feel I wouldn't doubt that some
executive made that dumb decision but
let's talk let's talk about so let's
let's talk about the movies you've done
tell us about them a little good so yes
if there's anywhere you can come find
them or watch them yeah I'll tell you
so my first film was called my man as a
loser it's I did it for Lionsgate bought
the movie it was an independent film
shot in New York and I wrote and
directed it was my debut writing
directing and I'd written a couple other
things that had kind of you know gotten
I had written one other movie that got
made that actually isn't even out yet
I didn't direct it but it's called
grounded with Aaron Paul Jeff Daniels
and Tom Berenger and that's actually
gonna be out later nice but while that
was getting done
I wrote my man as a loser and then while
they were actively it's a long crazy
story I don't know it's a long story but
like while they were actively looking
for a director that's when I convinced
them and said to them I promise you I
can direct this I went to U of A film
school basically but basically they were
truly looking for a bigger Nate a
big-name director I'd never directed
anything but because I wrote the script
I was tight with the producers and the
fire finance guys I was just you know on
a day-to-day basis with those guys and I
just read enough books did enough
research and they let me direct it so I
wrote and directed it and it's starring
Michael Rapaport John Stamos tika
Sumpter Bryan Callen fellow you know yes
about it's about two married dudes have
completely lost their way in their
marriages and they basically like get
their single buddy Stamos to like help
them get their swagger back to reconnect
with the wives
so Stamos is kinda like
single hitch type of thing you know and
it really started because these guys who
wanted to make a movie
they were like listen here's our story
and they started like really basically
just complaining about their wives no
job and they're just complaining and
they're like this is a story I said give
me a week like you don't really have a
full story but give me a week to take
what you're trying to say and like come
back to you
so I basically came back a week later
with like a beat sheet for him and I
said here's the story I think you're
trying to tell boom they hired me wrote
it and then it was like game on you know
it was like we started casting and I
casted Rapoport because I knew I was
already a fan of his and this character
was like so him and I I knew him from
basketball literally I was like dude I
think I got like a perfect thing for you
if you're like available and this before
he started blowing up in the podcast and
all this other crazy stuff mm-hmm but uh
so we met he read the script boom he was
in and then Stamos
I had met with like James Marsden was
gonna let's like one of those things he
was originally gonna play write the
Stamos part and his schedule got weird
and so we started taking some meetings
with like lead actors I met with Stamos
who I knew through Saget from stand-up
so it's really like a connection thing
and then Stamos he read it and he came
met me at lunch showed up made out of
caramel and Happiness handsome just
uncomfortably good-looking in a weird
restaurant I did one show that he had
years ago
yeah or is the list that show vh1 the
list and I think I don't know if they
rotated host but I so I did that show
with him and I remember just sitting
there going yeah he's beautiful and he
plays it up he comes in sunglasses in
the inside indoor sunglasses perfect
hair shirt unbuttoned a little bit it's
like he just shines and he goes I'm
gonna give him the full Stamos like he
probably looks in a mirror in his car he
goes I'm gonna give a full statement
100% Oh shirt unbuttoned three buttons
down no joke in the Beach Boys Band as a
drummer so he came in and we met and he
started just kind of telling his single
life stories which you can imagine our
next level yeah so I basically after the
after the meeting I just called the
producers and I was like there is nobody
that can tap into this character better
than this
like his his advice as a single guys
like you got to get the threesome out of
the way that's it's like on some planet
he's on another planet so I was like
this guy definitely a Brad Pitt movie I
said he's been around he's seen things
he's done things he's got it may they
made him the offer locked him in and
then Kallen oddly enough the third
character was just like a quirky funny
dude in Bryan Callen I've known from
stand-up comedy forever and I was it God
his voice kept like ringing in my head
and I'm like Bryan so I was on the road
with Cowan I'm not even kidding we're in
Miami doing the improv
I know that the movies going but I'm not
really telling anybody because you never
know things could fall apart so I go
we're in the coffee shop I'm like Bryan
I'm oh this sounds crazy but I'm doing
this movie and there's like a part that
you could you could probably have
because it's your voice bro and then
we're not gonna go spend a ton of money
on a movie star and it's indie he's a
guy I was like scattered anyways well
let me read it yeah I do movies so
Callen is one of the funniest people
aren't like just in life so he reads it
and comes to me the next days like dude
I love the script I'm in did it I called
the producers boom we had our three
dudes locked just like that and then we
went to New York and we casted everybody
else out of New York which was like an
amazing you know New York actors they
take their [ __ ] serious dude the extras
in New York got their [ __ ] locked down
you know there's stage actors no joke
extras in LA or some of them are crazy
yeah like there's a model who I just saw
it from a promoters table at a nightclub
yeah in LA some of them just got out of
the methadone clinic and they're going
back right after the audition 100% New
York every single perfect stage lists
the methadone clinic
as they should yeah but every actor in
New York that came in to read literally
was like okay this is all pro like there
was no bad audition so it was a tough it
was a tough process but once the train
started moving boom we cast this out of
New York we shot the whole movie and we
shot in 26 days in New York you know
six-week prep 26 days shoot put in the
can and then Lionsgate bought it and
they put it on they put it out like
theatrically for a minute yeah how did
how did Lionsgate get in did you get a
price we shot if we do not go to
festivals we shopped it to like four
companies
I forgot Lionsgate Sony focus a couple
other places and then you know I was
really out of that process it was really
like the money guys the producers right
I didn't that's kind of a hired gun a
little bit I was a hired gun a lot of it
was me fine it was great my first movie
I felt blessed but yeah they handled all
that business stuff so they basically
called and said hey Lionsgate wants the
movie and for their investors it was a
big thing because they got a lot of
their money back upfront and it was with
a company that was awesome and reputable
and you know it'll be released and it
got released and online it's done really
well like it went to what our iTunes and
then like Amazon Prime and whatever that
world is that I still don't even know a
lot about but everyone's happy in their
world so Lionsgate bought it and it's
been out now for like three years two
and a half yeah two and a half years and
then right after that I got my next
movie which was called a stand-up guy
which is on Netflix
so it was like it kind of it was like a
nice little I don't want some like
bragging right now Graham struggle it's
a crazy stroke and you still feel like
it's over that's the beauty the whole
you're always struggling it's over I got
two more movies coming it's over I'm
going back to school which I want to do
I'm gonna have to sneak people back in
the basketball game I'm back scalping if
you want to find me I'll be with Grandma
wood in the front of you of a spare down
state
and I'm not even kidding so yes so we
have the premiere of my man as a loser
it's a big Owen I put Ronny the limo
driver from Howard Stern Show he's a
really funny dude and I met him in New
York so I put him in the movie thinking
maybe Howard would like to promote the
movie which he did so Ronny was super
cool and that was like a fun smart
marketing move on my products tiny
brawny total stunt casting but he also
is he plays like a biker dude he is a
micro dude so we did that premiere in
New York after the premiere these two
guys one who I knew for who I've known
for years from LA he was with like one
of his finance film guys they were at
the premiere came to me after they like
we really enjoyed the movie it was fun
funny we're gonna we want to talk to you
about doing a comedy I was like no okay
everybody wants to talk about like okay
two weeks later they called and boom
they signed me on signed me to write a
stand-up guy just like that like
literally called me they had a different
idea
they had this I they had like a half an
idea like my first guys everyone's got
an idea but everybody wants to be in the
business but no one realizes like it's
so damn hard to have a true idea
beginning middle and ending that that's
and that's all that matters
I mean that's an actual script the units
so these guys that want to get in the
business they have like these half ideas
are like real kernels of like you know
passionate moments and I you know things
but not full scripts so they had an idea
i sat with it for a minute I called the
guy and I was like listen cuz I didn't
know if I could like even for the money
I wasn't the guy to write that so I
pitched them a stand-up guy which was
the story of like a gangster who goes
into witness protection program was like
a funny Street guy who accident who
starts doing stand-up while he's in the
program in a town and he becomes
accidentally famous because being from
Detroit
a former scalper sold a few things my
day but being from Detroit I always had
the thought of like if God forbid I ever
had to end up in witness protection when
I just stopped being funny like you just
turn it off yeah what'd I do what'd he
do so that was where the idea came from
they bought the idea wrote the script
shot at New York
and this company called the orchard
bought it and then naturally bought it
yeah so that was and that's what you
said so that's the movie you shot in
Detroit we had [ __ ] stolen out of it you
know the [ __ ] that got stolen was
actually the one that was the Aaron Paul
movie which I didn't direct Mike up and
all to write I wrote it
okay I wrote it and then executive
produced it but yeah they got a bunch of
[ __ ] stolen in Detroit you know I'm from
there I could have told him where to
park it's gonna yeah yeah now two of my
cousin's have have a half a million
dollar lighting situation it's weird
when you see an entire movie set show up
on eBay you know totally and a picture
of Aaron Paul in the core hey yeah so
well you at least got a taste right when
they sold the [ __ ] on the street after
he got stolen off the set right it's 5%
street tax yeah so that so a stand-up
guy was a really it was actually it was
a it was a million dollar budget and my
man is a loser was actually five million
which was a much bigger indie film but
there was something really awesome about
like shooting a small like contained
movie because even in the writing you
have to write towards your budget right
so you know there's no helicopter you
know you're on the street for like one
day you're not mounting cameras you
already know what that costs so it's
dialogue-driven and it's like very few
locations I'm very fuel ok makes you
more creative because you have to write
to the budget it does it puts you in a
really cool I love doing a cool creative
box and you go you know what it doesn't
cost money to write funny I mean that
doesn't cost anything so that was a real
good point I just want to integrate this
because we talked about this a lot on
the show is like how did this giant
budget movie tank how did it do poorly
because there was no restrictions there
was just spend whatever you want no one
will tell you no make this blow up pay
for this giant actor and then you're not
you need restraints you need that oh we
can't afford that or how do we make this
work because that's where you find the
Matt it works for definitely I mean
Deadpool right before shooting they cut
that budget and then they had to you
know figure out creative ways to not
shoot some of these set pieces and one
of them one
to be kept forgetting his guns so and
they they couldn't shoot this big
character it made more sense in the
context of the whole story by the way
that's that's a perfect example cuz that
the comedy of that you mean that
character they could have shot that for
I mean it's his it's those salaries that
costed a lot of money for yet above the
line above the line was huge on that but
yes if you get that same dialogue and
he's you know one about a comedian that
we know who can pull that off you have a
smash hit because it costs nothing to be
that funny right and I thought that's
why I Deadpool killed it was the you
know the the action with those jokes
were firing I don't know who ghosts
wrote like the punch up I don't get but
it was definitely a median yeah yeah
that's a comic voice in there that's a
stand-up voice you know that's like some
Joey di I'll show you what to do just
say this we're running out of time but
we should do our our patreon supporter
yes frightfully uninformed yeah go to
frightfully uninformed calm it's a
podcast that watches mostly classic
horror movies to figure out horror movie
fandom guys you can support the show for
$50 a month if you go to
patreon.com/scishow
do it and you know we are live right now
so why don't we plug some merchandise oh
yeah we've got our I don't know if we'll
have enough for everybody in the
audience but um yeah we'll try not to
run out this will be available back at
the comedy film nerd site you can get
the download on iTunes and Amazon and
we'll be selling them autographed
versions right here and shortly and we
also brought a couple of comedy film
nerds guide to movies look at that just
came out no no we did that on through
James working about four years ago a
couple years ago alright I gotta get
that I'll buy it one my yeah already
paid for three chicken quesadillas but
yeah so alright but before you write so
Mike what do you got what's coming up
next on my neck my next movie is called
the district and actually um it's set in
the 1970s it's actually a drama
in the 70s garment district when the mob
used to run the garment industry in New
York City and the guy who ran it his son
and they're all your movie shoot in New
York and if they don't you get [ __ ]
stolen you don't come with me to New
York all your [ __ ] is gone no but I've
been lucky man like the New York I've
just been lucky the first two were there
and then the one was in Detroit but uh
yeah this next was gonna be in New York
so I got to I really went in deep on the
garment district and what it was was
basically the organized crime families
like the Gambino's used to run the
trucking routes and the manufacturers
and you didn't get your shirt and no
Macy's window without paying these guys
so when you thought like you know East
st. Laurent and Ralph Lauren and Nicole
Miller you thought they were so cool and
fashion they had to kick up to the mob
in the 70s and so the guy that ran it
his son got ahold of me and found me to
write the movie and so so you got the
rights from him I got the well no he
it's his it's his right his father's
story so they hired me to write it so I
wrote it and then boom now we're in
motion and we're going not for not till
after New Year's so we're like where are
we
pre-production number today we'll start
prepping right after the new year right
yeah so are you still casting it or yeah
we are we're still casting it well if
you need a guy that knows how to scalp
tickets at an Arizona game well open on
you at bare downstate those good and
then what else working people find you
online or whatever find me I'm the worst
social media but I'm getting better now
I'm another one with all things comedy
wrote it's a new it's a family yeah so
the real Mike Young is my Instagram and
Twitter just real Mike Young and you've
got past podcast stories that need to be
told
check it out all things comedy and yeah
I've been right you know I got a couple
other little writing pieces that are
going but why brag you know we don't do
that you had this all worked out we're
like man who's our guest can you guys
Bird your beef it's great yeah let me
just tell you gram literally I know
you've done much more since then
when you you didn't even really tell me
back in the day that you were like a
comedian and I went with my boys to see
Barry Silva I'm like [ __ ] scalper
partner he's killing the game my comedy
career under wraps cuz they didn't want
to mess up with my scalp I mean who the
hell knew how to do comedy in college I
did you guys were just ahead of the
curve I just knew it a young age I could
I didn't have a skill for a real job
well Mike thanks for this is awesome it
was great having you and good luck with
the film and stuff like that Chris what
do we got a what are we anything else we
needed oh we did our merchandise plugs
yeah and of course oh and we want to
mention this too in a couple of days ear
buds will be back for sale on the comedy
film nerd site the digital and the DVDs
so our our blocked window is now over
but if you prefer the the iTunes or the
Amazon format or ever you can obviously
it'll be on those those formats we don't
care where you buy it as long as you buy
it buy it yes and then what else is
going on yeah my other stuff political
vigilante and I'm doing a I'm emceeing a
show at flappers for this FNX is this
Native American Channel they're gonna
start doing a stand-up comedy show that
I'm gonna be involved with so we're
having a showcase this Sunday the 29th
at flappers in Burbank at 7 p.m. in the
yoohoo room come by and check that out
and there's a bunch of cool comics you
may have never heard of mark Jaffe Jim
rule and a couple others Rosie Tran
they're gonna be on the show so take
that out and then I'll be given more
news about that epinet show as we get
closer to it and I always check out the
comedy film nerds patreon we always need
support there and my other podcasts was
scripted Twilight Zone podcast
conversations from the abyss is also out
right now yeah so go to comedy Filner's
dot-com you guys like support all that
stuff we appreciate any way that you can
support the show positive reviews and
then of course all my show and tour
dates are at grandma would calm and all
Afghanistan is now available on Amazon
so both our film check it out
laughs ganna Stan and your buds are
available on
on other platforms and we want to thank
everybody here didn't you watch him both
together
did you have a grandma with night you
have a grandma I've seen me with curly
Mac Davis haircut freaking out in a war
zone that in capitals with gold and then
yeah yeah
laughs ganas debt is my wig out it's my
freak out I'm actually everyone goes
down the river I go down the river and I
lose my [ __ ] it's real time and actually
happened and I'm here to talk about it
but thank you to everybody at ATC Aaron
thanks Ari
for setting up the studio there's all
the people that came out to watch thank
you was here the guy with the obi-wan
Kenobi he's our only hope campaign shirt
can't imagine that that's a comedy film
nerd fan folks that really showed up and
everybody here thanks again Mike Young
thank you my name is Graham Elwood and
I'm Chris Mancini and as always remember
Han shot first thank you don't